Before the break, I showed you
redditor CountPikmin's proposed
battle between Bernie Sanders
and Colonel Sanders. I asked you
to give me your arguments
for who would win.
Let's see what you came up with.
First one...
HARDWICK (reading):
Or, or...
Who was number two?
Ron Funches has won
the Internet!
MALE VOICE:
For the win!
Funches wins the Internet.
Congratulations to Ron!
He is the winner
of the @midnight Late Night
Showdown and the funniest person
in the world for
the next 23 and a half hours.
Also, thanks to Mike Yard
from The Nightly Show
with Larry Wilmore.
Thanks to Honda Civic
for making this happen.
Thanks to Jordan Klepper
from The Daily Show.